[Music]
tony joins us up next in raleigh north
carolina tony welcome to the show
oh hey george hey christina how are you
we're doing great what's going on with
you
um i know i
had kind of sold my vehicle about a year
year or so ago um to kind of fast track
um becoming debt free which i am now
nice i know my
uh my sister actually had a car that was
kind of just sitting
at my parents house on her old car so i
kind of fixed it up put about two
thousand bucks into it
and uh kind of have you know driven that
um since last last year sometime
beginning of last year and i think um it
was kind of for my niece she's going to
be graduating from high school soon so i
know her parents weren't going to have
the money to fix it up so it was kind of
a win-win for both of us
but i know she's going to be getting her
license um pretty soon um and i knew
this ahead of time but i did become
debt-free um i don't want to go back
into getting another um auto loan i'm
scared that might affect me and
uh you know saving towards my emergency
fund um or also you know home buying
later down the road so i just wanted to
know what my um exactly what my options
were now
well your options are to buy a car with
cash and that means we're going to buy a
car with cash and save up and buy a car
with cash
so what kind of car would you be looking
at
um i know in my research i definitely
know now i want a toyota or honda just a
basic you know sedan corolla civic good
man you know something you sold okay
so have you looked at your area in
raleigh and said hey what is a you know
what's a 2012 civic gonna cost
yeah i have um you know i just know now
with my you know my emergency fund um at
about uh at about four or five thousand
now on that in that emergency fund um
and i know she's gonna be
you know get her parents don't live here
um they actually live in greensboro so i
know that i'm gonna have to be giving
her that you know that car back soon so
that's where the the worry came in we
got to get the emergency fund beefed up
but also get you a car asap yeah
how soon do you have to give it back
um i would say within the next i would
say maybe five six months or so okay and
you got the car for free but you put two
grand of repairs into it
yeah yeah
okay yeah
so if we got a few months how what's
your income
about 50 52 000 a year okay what do you
do for a living
i'm in an operations airport cool
well
how quickly could you get a 10 000
emergency fund and then save up another
six or seven to get a car
so we're talking another 15 000 saved
within
four months
yeah
what would that take could you take some
side jobs some side hustles
yeah i could work overtime i don't know
what your situation is at work
yeah i could work with yeah i can work
some overtime um definitely you know
have a few jobs here or there
just to make up the income yeah and this
is for a short season i'm not talking
two years of this i'm saying for four
months can we basically double our
income in order to be in a real good
spot when we have to hand over this car
and i would get really clear on the
timeline of this like you're saying
maybe five to six months but obviously
if we're trying to save super
aggressively and get to that goal of a
car a month or two is going to make a
huge difference so i would have that
conversation as soon as possible just to
figure that out so then you can map out
you know what do i need to save each
month how many extra jobs do i need to
get what does this journey actually look
like and you also may want to adjust the
type of car you get like if you're if
they're like hey we need this car in two
to three months i mean maybe you're
looking at a 5 000 car for right now and
then you can save up and get something
better in the future yeah it's a great
point there and if you could just say
hey listen i'm gonna have this money by
march does that work for you guys can i
give her the car then
and if they're a little bit flexible or
she can borrow a car for now and give
you a little more time that's going to
really help your situation
okay
are they pretty flexible sounds good
yes they are um yeah i guess i just kind
of got caught up in the
i guess further
i guess further down the road you know
where we are now and you know just rent
prices and things like that i kind of
start to get a little worried
um you know that that would kind of
affect the budget you know in terms of
if i were to get another car or if
they're not you know flexible if i do
have to give it back
so i was just kind of a little nervous
just a little nervous about that
well have no fear we're going to create
a sinking fund line item in your budget
that is for that new car and we might
put that in a separate savings account
versus your emergency fund because it
can get all squirrely when you're just
looking at one savings account going
well i have enough for a car but i don't
know if i have my emergency fund now so
i would separate the two and get set up
a new savings account just for the car
and that way you know exactly where you
stand at all times
sounds perfect but your a1 is getting
that emergency fund beefed up to three
to six months of expenses do you know
your monthly expenses right now
um yeah i'm at about i would say about
20 about 500. 2500.
okay
so four months would be 10 i would say
maybe about 1700 i'm sorry 17. oh okay
so we're talking about 10 grand or so
would be a fully funded emergency fund
and you're you're close to that and so
within a few months you'll be there and
then the next few months you're going to
be focused on saving up for that car and
whenever you have to give it back
whatever car we can get for that amount
of money that's what we do and maybe it
may mean getting scrappy and we're going
to facebook marketplace and craigslist
and negotiating and doing it with a you
know cashier's check and trying to get a
deal but that's going to be your best
bet
sounds good well it's obvious to you
that you're willing to drive a car that
you fixed up and that that's what you've
been driving recently so i think if you
just kind of keep that mindset of like
i'm not really going for it no one's
gonna be impressed with this car
and that's okay we're running our own
race and tony's good with that
appreciate the call man